Hi, everyone. This is Anne from counters clinic and today we're going to talk about thieves essential oil
So thieves has a white label and the cranberry colored label the white label is approved to take internally so you can actually put drops in your mouth
Or you can put drops in a capsule and take it as a supplement
The cranberry colored label is approved for topical use. You can diffuse it or you can use it in making your own
household products
So what is thieves?
Thieves is a blend of clove, lemon, cinnamon bark, eucalyptus, radiata, and rosemary and all of these essential oils have constituents in them that are
scientifically proven to enhance your immune system and they have properties, antibacterial properties to help kill viruses, bacteria, and mold.
So that's what thieves is most commonly known for.
So how do we use thieves? So you can use it again like I said. You can make your own household cleaners
This really helps. It's a toxic chemical-free cleaner when you are using thieves and making your own
cleaners
You can spray it on your laundry to help make it smell a little better or again to help eliminate any
bacteria or mold that has maybe developed on some of your kids sporting equipment or something like that
You can use it as hand sanitizer. You can also apply it topically to
your gums. If your gums are feeling inflamed or you feel something going on, you know, with your teeth or having an oral infection
It can help heal rashes or cuts and it can even get help get rid of pimples. Now what thieves is in oil that has
Some heat to it. There's some spiciness to it. So you might need to blend it with some coconut oil
To help to help take that heat down if you're applying it topically
Like I said, you can put drops in your mouth and it will help boost the immune system help kill off any
viruses that you might be exposed to if you feel cold coming on
You can diffuse it and it helps purify the air and it helps to alleviate allergy symptoms and even headaches
You also can rub thieves on the bottom of your feet and this is a really great place to just kind of absorb
The thieves to help it work systemically throughout your body to help support your body
We also have something in clinic that we sell here. It's called thieves goat milk soap
So this is handmade soap that has the thieves in it
There's also a number of products that are available that are already made if you're not really into the DIY thing
You can reach out to us here at Conner's clinic and we can help you get set up with any laundry detergent tooth paste
They're already made for you household cleaner and all of this just helps create a healthier environment for your children
for yourselves when we're limiting
To any toxic exposures that we cannot like those in the household cleaners by making some of our own
We are just helping support our whole system and improving the health of our children and our family. I hope this helps. Thank you